hey guys I'm Ryan right so I'm excited
to watch the trailer for this movie
called police story lockdown I don't
know which police story number this is I
saw the first four in case you guys are
now super cop was actually Police Story
three and Jackie Chan's first strike was
actually police story for I grew up on a
lot of Hong Kong cinema I haven't been
up-to-date in the last few years but I
grew up around the time when there was
like Jackie Chan gently you and Bo Sam
along Shelley Oh Cynthia Rothrock so I'm
excited to see this trailer because
Jackie Chan was one of my heroes
literally like if there was one person
who was my favorite superstar when he
was like a huge superstar in America it
was Jackie Chan the admiration I have
for this guy is ridiculous like he he
doesn't just do brilliant fight scenes
like he was opposite of Bruce Lee he
invented a whole new type of fighting
that had a lot of humor in it they
involved props from being from
everything around you you know and he
did his own stunts and some of those
stunts are [ __ ] insane you know a lot
of people aren't familiar with like a
lot of the Hong Kong films he did and
this those are where his craziest stunts
are like he has a permanent hole in his
head because of one stunt from armor of
God but he's also funny he's a he's a
pretty good actor actually I mean if you
only go off his American films you might
think he's just okay but in Hong Kong I
think he was really respected actor he's
the ultimate entertainer and I hear his
politics aren't the greatest these days
but whatever is still a big inspiration
to me and I hope he gets back some
superstar fame and in America
what your formula
at any Jackie Chan just shoot himself in
the head at the end yeah oh boy oh boy
um like I said I only saw the first more
police stories I remember those movies
having a pretty big sense of humor I
feel like all humor has gone out the
window and now it's this super serious
crime drama which I can get on board
with you know like today's times we tend
to like from action movies you know you
don't get a lot of Kingsman the Secret
Service you get more of like those
Bourne films where it's like really dark
gritty action and Jackie Chan was known
for his sense of humor he was known for
doing a lot of comedy it's interesting
to see them promoting a film that's not
what we remember from Jackie Chan doing
that it's actually like this really
hard-hitting crime tale where it looks
like Jackie Chan will give a pretty
badass performance I mean there's some
action movie cliches chick gets
kidnapped Jackie Chan gets captured and
then that's the breakout you know like
he's tied to a chair how often are
heroes tied to a chair the time frame of
when this movie takes place looks really
interesting to me I feel like it takes
place in like one night it's called
lockdown so I feel like it takes place
in just one night I like movies that
take place in like one day or the span
of two days it's it's cool to me when a
film messes with the real time a little
bit it's not exactly real time but it
messes with that Jackie Chan is like
[ __ ] 60 or some [ __ ] I don't know how
these but Jackie Chan looks pretty good
for his age and it's gonna be cool to
see some brutal fight scenes from the
guy I hope this gets some popularity in
America because this could reinvent his
image and it would be cool to see him in
movies in America that are more along
the lines of this something that's like
a really hard-hitting crime drama like
when he first came out to America he did
a film called the protector which was an
American crime dramas so [ __ ] bad
though and he hasn't had the chance to
do that with an American film since so I
hope somehow Americans get a hold of
this film
and we'll want to see Jackie Chan and
films like that rather than just seeing
a another sequel to Shanghai noon or
another rush hopper film breeding time
if police story lockdown gets released
in a theater near me I will watch it
alright guys thanks for tuning in if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
we can get product placement that's
right
like cardboard cutouts my father was a
drinker cardboard cutouts are awesome
you know I have one of these in my
bedroom but it's an exact replica of me
with my penis hanging out my penis is
about 12 inches long it's like hanging
you know like right here where it cuts
off my penis is actually hanging and
then we have to extend the cardboard
because of my big penis anyway yeah I
will never get actual product placement
because I cannot stop talking about my
dick